[snaps]
First things first.
I do not care that you're
a multi-platinum selling
rapper, Gun Rack.
What I care about
is that I, 100%,
know that you murdered
Darnell Simmons.
So,
you better start talking.
[dramatic music]
♪ ♪
[softly] Yeah,
but you ain't got nothing.
Oh. Uh, you know,
I'm actually, I'm very glad
that you said that.
Because I--respectfully,
I beg to differ.
[hip hop music
on tape player]
♪ I killed Darnell, yeah,
I shot him with my nine ♪
♪ I shot him nine times,
9:00 p.m. on the dime ♪
♪ And by the way,
it was November 9th ♪
[music stops]
That don't mean nothing.
I got a vivid imagination.
I couldn't have shot
Darnell.
I was at my cousin's
birthday party.
Red Lobster, November 9th.
- At Red Lobster?
- Mm hmm.
Geez, I got to tell you,
Gun Rack,
I find that really hard
to believe.
[music continues]
- ♪ I got an alibi ♪
♪ Birthday,
Red Lobster ♪
♪ When in reality I shot
Darnell like a mobster ♪
♪ It's a lie,
Anyone could tell this ♪
♪ Because I got an allergy
to all shellfish ♪
[music stops]
Just confess, Gun Rack.
I confess that "shellfish"
is the only thing
that rhymes with "tell this".
It's just words, Detective.
Nouns, adjectives.
That just happen to be
in a dope order.
But...you ain't got no proof.
[music continues]
- ♪ Shot up Darnell ♪
♪ With a long-ass gun ♪
♪ And I tossed it
into the aquarium ♪
♪ ♪
I have no idea
what that object is.
- I don't--
- If I had to identify it,
I would call it a gun
of the long-ass variety.
Some seaweed in there, too.
Look, Detective.
I hate to break it to you.
I ain't kill nobody.
[music continues]
♪ I stroke my chin real slow
when I'm lying ♪
♪ And I was laughing super hard
as Darnell was dying ♪
The name of the album
is I Killed Darnell Simmons.
- It's a concept album.
- A concept--
That's a picture of you.
A picture of you, and behind you
is Darnell Simmons's body!
Coincidence.
You're going away
for a long time, you understand?
You're gonna confess if it's
the last thing you ever do,
you hear me, Gun Rack?
I'll beat it out of you.
- Joe.
- I'll beat it out of you.
Joe!
He's free to go.
What?
No. No, no, no, no, no.
We have everything
we need.
No, it was Simmons's
girlfriend.
She just confessed
to the whole thing.
Infidelity.
Crime of passion.
Let's go, Mr. Rack.
[dramatic music]
♪ ♪
[music from tape player]
- Bonus track, bonus track.
♪ Got a ride or die bitch ♪
♪ I think you get the gist ♪
♪ And when you let me out,
I'm gonna blow a little kiss ♪
♪ Consider this my confession
admissible in a court ♪
♪ I killed Darnell Simmons
for sport ♪
[laughs]
♪ That's right, I'm a murderer ♪
- ♪ Come and get me ♪
- Hector, stop!
♪ You can't,
come down the hall and get me ♪
♪ Okay, okay,
you got me ♪
You got me, you got me.
Yes. Whoa, whoa. Damn.
Ow, ow!